ya hemos estado hablando un montón de
tiempo acerca de las proteínas acerca de
la enorme variedad de cosas que hacen en
los sistemas biológicos desde actuar
como hormonas o anticuerpos hasta
proveer estructuras en las células o ser
mecanismos de señalización y toda una
serie de cosas y ahora su habilidad para
hacer todo ese tipo de cosas en los
sistemas vivos proviene es un producto
de su estructura así es que de lo que
vamos a hablar en este vídeo es de la
estructura de las proteínas y para poder
realmente apreciar la estructura de las
proteínas vamos a observar a una
molécula de hemoglobina lo que hay por
aquí tenemos una molécula de hemoglobina
y las moléculas de hemoglobina están
compuestas por cuatro cadenas poli
peptídicas dos de ellas tienen 141
aminoácidos y las otras dos tienen 146
aminoácidos así es que en total
en 574 aminoácidos 574 aminoácidos pero
como podemos ver esos aminoácidos no
están en alguna configuración aleatoria
están organizados en cierta
configuración que es muy buena para
hacer lo que hace la hemoglobina lo cual
es transportar oxígeno la hemoglobina es
muy buena transportando oxígeno dentro
de las células rojas y bueno así como
tenemos las proteínas de la hemoglobina
hay muchísimos muchísimos muchísimos
otros tipos de proteínas que hacen un
montón de otro tipo de cosas pero como
le hacen para obtener su estructura y
bueno una forma de pensar en todo esto
es ver que hay diferentes niveles de
estructura y el primer nivel de la
estructura le podemos llamar estructura
primaria
y esta es simplemente el orden de los
aminoácidos que componen a esta proteína
cuando hablamos acerca del paso de la
traducción que tenemos por ahí algún
mensajero a rn m que llega a un ribosoma
y luego hay por ahí algunos a rn de
transferencia arnette que se dedican a
traer aminoácidos y juntarlos y se
empiezan a enlazar entre ellos justo ahí
es donde se está formando la estructura
primaria y justo el adn o bueno la
información en el adn lo que está
programando es esto de aquí aunque yo
está programando en qué orden se van a
enlazar los aminoácidos así es que la
estructura primaria es simplemente el
orden en el que se encuentran los
aminoácidos el orden de los aminoácidos
la estructura primaria es simplemente el
orden es simplemente como formamos a
nuestro polipéptido a partir de los
aminoácidos
pero también nos podemos preguntar cómo
le hace el poli péptido para doblarse de
todas estas formas y poder hacer todo
ese tipo de cosas que necesita hacer
bueno pues en la estructura secundaria
estructura secundaria y la estructura
secundaria se debe a las interacciones
que hay en el esqueleto proteico y tengo
unos cuantos ejemplos de eso por aquí
como podemos ver por aquí tenemos una
cadena poli peptídica tenemos un montón
de aminoácidos que están enlazados con
estos enlaces peptídicos esto de aquí es
un enlace peptídicos ok y por aquí
también tenemos otro enlace peptídicos
entre el carbono del grupo carbon hilo y
el nitrógeno y buscamos otro carbono del
grupo carbón y lo enlazado con un
nitrógeno y tenemos otro enlace
peptídicos y fácilmente nos podemos
imaginar que esta cadena poli peptídica
ajá por aquí pero luego vuelve a subir y
vuelve a bajar pero por aquí estamos
viendo que cuando vuelve a bajar tiene
el mismo sentido
aquí tenemos nitrógeno y luego el
carbono del grupo carbón y lo luego el
enlace peptídicos y otra vez nitrógeno
carbono del grupo carbón hilo y enlace
peptídicos y lo que estamos viendo por
aquí es que el esqueleto del polipéptido
está interactuando incluso decidí no
dibujar las cadenas laterales y poner
simplemente una r por aquí para cada una
de las distintas cadenas laterales para
hacer más énfasis en cómo interactúa el
esqueleto del polipéptido ok por ejemplo
aquí tenemos este nitrógeno que es mucho
más electro negativo que este hidrógeno
por lo cual el nitrógeno está abrazando
los electrones de este enlace y el
hidrógeno tiene una carga parcial
positiva por otro lado tenemos aquí a
este oxígeno que es más electro negativo
que el carbono y por lo tanto está
abrazando a los electrones de este
carbono y tiene una carga parcial
negativa y entonces este hidrógeno y
este oxígeno se van a sentir atraídos y
se va a formar un puente de hidrógeno
porque hay este es uno de esos
famosísimos puentes de hidrógeno y lo
mismo está sucediendo por aquí aunque
también lo mismo está sucediendo por acá
y entonces estas dos cadenas pueden
formar como una hoja o una lámina y
bueno de hecho se les llama así se les
llama hoja plegada beta o bueno también
algunas veces se le llama lámina beta y
ahora por aquí también construyó una
hoja plegada beta pero tal vez puedas
encontrar fácilmente la diferencia entre
estas dos por aquí y vamos del nitrógeno
al carbono alfa
este es el carbono alfa al carbono del
grupo carbón y lo y luego otra vez al
nitrógeno aunque lleve el nitrógeno al
carbono alfa
es otro carbono alfa al carbono del
grupo carbon hilo y otra vez al
nitrógeno y de este lado también
estábamos viendo en la misma dirección
empezábamos el nitrógeno carbono alfa
carbono del grupo carbón y lo nitrógeno
y luego otra vez carbono alfa carbono
del grupo carbon hilo y nitrógeno así es
que esta es una hoja plegada beta
paralela estos dos esqueletos que están
interactuando están yendo en la misma
dirección
así es que diríamos que esta hoja
plegada beta es paralela que es una hoja
plegada beta paralela mientras que en
esta otra de aquí ok podemos ver que los
esqueletos son paralelos pero podemos
ver por aquí que estamos yendo del
nitrógeno al carbono alfa al carbono del
grupo carbón y lo nitrógeno carbono alfa
carbono del grupo carbón y lo nitrógeno
esto es lo que sucede del lado izquierdo
pero del lado derecho estamos viendo
nitrógeno carbono
grupo carbón hilo carbono alfa nitrógeno
carbono del grupo carbón hilo carbono
alfa nitrógeno
estamos yendo en la dirección opuesta de
hecho hasta lo dibujé de cabeza lo que
hay bueno en realidad nada más tome este
esqueleto y lo volteé y lo pegue por acá
y por eso están las letras de cabeza
aunque hay pero seguimos teniendo estos
puentes de hidrógeno estos puentes de
hidrógeno entre el hidrógeno que tiene
una carga parcial positiva porque el
hidrógeno es más electro negativo y este
oxígeno que tiene una carga parcial
negativa que hay por aquí seguimos
teniendo estos puentes de hidrógeno
y también tenemos que los esqueletos son
paralelos pero estamos yendo en
direcciones opuestas
así es que diríamos que estas son hojas
plegadas beta anti paralelas anti
paralelas hoja plegada beta anti
paralela o también conocida como lámina
beta anti paralela así es que esta es
otra forma de estructura secundaria y
luego por aquí tenemos esta cosa y
podemos ver que este esqueleto tiene una
forma de hélice y aquí tenemos puentes
de hidrógeno entre los distintos niveles
de la hélice por aquí tenemos este
oxígeno que tiene una carga parcial
negativa y un hidrógeno que tiene una
carga parcial positiva y se forma un
puente de hidrógeno entre estos dos y
por acá también se forma un puente de
hidrógeno y esto es lo que le da la
estructura de hélice
esta le llamamos hélice alfa entonces
estas interacciones entre los esqueletos
de los polis péptidos vamos para arriba
y esas interacciones entre los
esqueletos de los polipéptidos es lo que
forma la estructura secundaria pero
todavía no terminemos porque como te
puedes imaginar estas cadenas laterales
también nos dicen algo acerca de la
estructura de la proteína algunas de
estas cadenas laterales pueden ser
hidrofóbicas y entonces pueden tratar de
huir del exterior y pueden tratar de
irse hacia adentro de la molécula o
también puede ser que algunas de estas
cadenas laterales formen puentes de
hidrógeno entre sí y entonces están
interactuando de cierta forma también
podemos tener cadenas laterales que
formen enlaces de sulfuro o incluso
enlaces covalentes con algunas otras
cadenas laterales y vamos a ver esto con
mucho más detalle pronto en algún otro
vídeo pero por el momento en este vídeo
el tercer nivel de estrés
es la estructura terciaria y la
estructura terciaria se debe a las
interacciones entre las cadenas
laterales se debe a las interacciones
entre cadenas laterales no os podemos
imaginar que tenemos por aquí nuestra
proteína
y tal vez tengo un montón de cadenas
laterales hidrofóbicas por aquí ya todas
las estoy llamando r pero supongamos que
son diferentes cadenas hidrofóbicas y
que por ejemplo el agua está por aquí
afuera y entonces estas cadenas
laterales hidrofóbicas van a tratar de
alejarse del agua y bueno también puede
ser que tengas cadenas laterales que
sean hidrofílicas que sean polares y
esas cadenas laterales tal vez van a
querer estar del lado del agua también
podemos tener una situación en la que
tenemos una cadena r 1 y en algún otro
lugar tengamos una cadena r 2 y que se
forme un puente de hidrógeno entre estas
dos cadenas laterales o tal vez en lugar
de un puente de hidrógeno tienen un
enlace iónico así es que podemos pensar
en un montón de diferentes tipos de
interacciones entre las cadenas
laterales y vamos a ver todo eso a fondo
pero en un vídeo próximamente ahora
cualquier proteína que esté compuesta
únicamente por un solo polipéptido va a
tener únicamente estructura primaria
secundaria y terciaria sin embargo si
estamos tratando con una proteína como
la hemoglobina que está formada por más
de un poli péptido entonces vamos a
poder hablar de la estructura
cuaternaria estructura cuaternaria y
ésta se trata de cómo se juntan las
distintas cadenas de polipéptidos para
formar moléculas más complejas y más
largas
la estructura cuaternaria la define el
arreglo de varias cadenas poli
peptídicas el arreglo de varias en el
caso de la hemoglobina fueron cuatro
cadenas poli peptídicas cadenas poli
peptídicas bueno espero que esto te haya
dado una muy buena idea de la estructura
de las proteínas que por cierto es toda
un área fascinante no crear porque hay
muchísimas permutaciones para construir
distintas
proteínas y si las lográramos entender
mejor podríamos pasar mucho más fácil
del adn a la estructura primaria y luego
de la estructura primaria podríamos
entender mucho mejor cómo funcionan las
proteínas que hacen y cómo arreglarlas y
qué podemos hacer para tal vez
proporcionar algunas proteínas que hagan
algunas otras funciones
así es que esto de la estructura de las
proteínas es todo un tema súper
fascinante es verdaderamente un campo de
estudio increíble